Speaker 1: We suspected.
Let me let me back up.
When Trump got COVID.
We knew we were being lied to about a lot
of different thing.
Earlier in the week and
Speaker 2: last week, we came to learn
Speaker 1: that one of the things we were
being
Speaker 2: lied about with regard to
Speaker 1: Trump's COVID was when he was sick.
And it is now
Speaker 2: abundantly clear before it was
Speaker 1: 90 percent clear.
Now it's completely clear Trump had had a
positive test before
Speaker 2: that infamous debate with Joe Biden,
at which Trump
Speaker 1: showed up late and his
Speaker 2: staff said, We don't know.
Trust us.
Speaker 1: He was tested.
We're not going to test on site.
Speaker 2: He was tested for COVID.
Speaker 1: We now know Trump had COVID during
that debate.
We also suspected that Trump was way sicker
Speaker 2: than was being admitted
Speaker 1: to by his doctors and his aides
political aides at that time.
And we now have more information about that.
Thanks again to Mark Meadows.
Trump's form, one of Trump's former chiefs
of staff who
Speaker 2: has now published a
Speaker 1: ton of information about what was
going on behind the scenes, we have learned,
number one, that Donald Trump's oxygen was
not just a little low, but it was dangerously
low back in October of 2020, when he tested
positive for COVID
Speaker 2: 19.
Speaker 1: We also learned
Speaker 2: that the
Speaker 1: diagnosis in general was far more
serious, that Trump's medical team actually
pulled Mark Meadows aside and said, Listen.
His oxygen levels are really, really low for
his age, 86 or
Speaker 2: lower is very, very dangerous.
Speaker 1: There is also the revelation now
that Donald Trump was so weak that he could
not even carry his
Speaker 2: own briefcase
Speaker 1: and that Mark Meadows was advised.
You've got to convince Trump to get to Walter
Reed Hospital now before things take a turn
for the worse.
Because if you're trying to hide how sick
he is, if the guy can't even walk to the helicopter,
it's going to be
Speaker 2: impossible, impossible
Speaker 1: to continue hiding it.
Meadows went in to tell Trump, Sir, you know,
we got to move you.
It's time to go to Walter Reed.
Trump was supposedly sitting up in bed in
a T-shirt and looked like he was not going
to be able to go anywhere.
And Meadows says, You know, we always saw
the guy in either golf workouts or suit got
golf outfits or a suit and tie, and Trump
looked very, very different here.
He was a mess.
His hair was a mess on and on.
And Mark Meadows said to
Speaker 2: Trump, It's better.
Speaker 1: You walk out of here today under
your own power
Speaker 2: than being brought out on a gurney
or a stretcher.
Speaker 1: And that was the time at which
it was determined by Trump.
Yeah, I'd better go.
And the idea was, OK, let's go out and carry
your briefcase.
Speaker 2: But he's too weak even to carry
the
Speaker 1: briefcase we have
Speaker 2: now learned now.
Speaker 1: Are any of these details surprising?
No.
We had every reason to suspect
Speaker 2: that
Speaker 1: Trump was very, very sick and much
sicker than was being admitted.
Is Trump now admitting that this is what went
on?
No, no.
Trump is denying these accounts and saying,
I didn't have COVID during the debate.
It's fake news.
All this different stuff.
Speaker 2: Trump denies everything, so it
seems pretty clear
Speaker 1: to me if you say, Well, what's
the most likely thing here?
What's the most reasonable and likely explanation?
Mark Meadows is probably telling the truth.
I don't know of any reason, particularly when
you know that if you tell these stories being
Mark Meadows, Trump is going to lose his mind
is going to slam you.
It's going to be completely crazy.
And at the same time, it follows what we knew
at the time.
Dr. Sean Conley was
Speaker 2: being very,
Speaker 1: very squishy and evasive with is
did Trump need oxygen?
He's not on oxygen today.
No.
But did he?
In the past since coming here, he has not
been on oxygen today.
OK, when did he first test positive?
I'm not going to look backwards.
We want to look forward to the president regaining
his help.
Speaker 2: It all fits with everything that
was going on, Trump always
Speaker 1: wanting to minimize anything bad
and play up anything good.
The very strange and narrow language used
by his doctors and on and on and on.
So no shock.
No surprise.
Just imagine.
I mean, I think the real takeaway here is
imagine how crazy things would have gotten.
Had Trump refused to go to the hospital initially
and ultimately needed to be brought on a stretcher,
but what would that have done?
And if Trump had ended up even sicker and
stayed in the hospital closer to the elections?
I mean it all
Speaker 2: the way it went ended up seeming
Speaker 1: not that bad for Trump at the end
of the day.
Still, ultimately did not get him reelected,
but it could have been much, much worse.
And we're learning that through these revelations
from Mark Meadows,